come on get over here right now hi hi
you asked for us have you seen these
numbers can you explain why our
superhero movies have been miss after
missed right I don't think it's been
that bad the sixth Scream movie is
outperforming you right now oh you got
me there you're supposed to be our cash
cow now people are out there watching
original movies
what the I don't know sir it's
tough look Shazam I expected this from
you no no yeah for sure but Marvel
what's your excuse I think people are
having what we call Marvel fatigue
there's so much stuff that it just
doesn't feel special anymore so what are
you gonna do about it make even more
stuff to be fair sir I thought my
strategy was airtight and what was that
strategy if I may ask publicly announced
that the whole DC Universe is being
reset and most of the movies now don't
really matter yeah that sounds airtime
honestly honestly I'm a little insulted
to be included in his company right now
okay and we are not the same we're
basically this fellas please
you both suck thank you